ragazzi dovete scusarmi se mi vedete un
po strano però ho avuto la febbre fino
anzi sono ancora un pochettino siamo
stati su 100 floor 100 piani siamo
arrivati al livello livello 50 era una
cagata pasta va a bussare sulla porta
siamo al 51
l'esito non mi ricordo ma perché penso
sempre ai cubisti gameplay che non
servono una sedia c'è una spada nel
disegnare la spada scommetti grazie
minecraft ma insegnata craftare le cose
possiamo fare a modo mio come al solito
ragazzi la mia tattica funziona la cia
la già adottata ve lo dico è troppo ci
sono troppi numeri mi sa che non riesco
a farlo solo cosi kaka peccato ci sono
così tanti numeri fa questa tattica
funziona spesso apparse come tali dal
più grande al più piccolo a quali sono
gli elementi di natale maledizione a1 è
il regalo dopo il regalo abbiamo i
fiocchi qua per forza preso due le
trombe 2 e poi le palle che sono
valevole conto tutte però sono tipo
mille facciamo gruppi sono cinque
quando io la febbre non posso fare stavo
scherzando quando sto male non capì non
ragiono quindi non so però funzionato va
bene devo puntare gli elementi di natale
non erano esseri però stai calmo è
questo potrebbe essere un problema visto
che non so cos'è assassina stacca la
spina perfetto prendi le cose apri coso
ciao poveri no grazie come si toglie il
wifi schifo di telefono prefetto ha
finalmente un bel quesito matematico
così butto il telefono abbiamo
esattamente quello di cui ho bisogno
cioè morire allora se 941 più 2 one two
three four mine squander tweakweek ma
adattato se clicco su a uguale 01 si
illumina che non è male
intel code devo inserire code la parola
code però in codice se quindi la lettera
ci corrisponde al 3 a 0 1 lettera c e 0
la lettera osta per
15 la di abcd 04 la mio dio gesù esiste
mamma mia che brutto gioco andiamo
avanti per favore io non sono capaci
matematica vi giuro sono passato perché
copiavo basta l'ho detto che il
professore sono passato perché copiavo
da nepi che è lo studente peruviano che
avevo di fianco era bravissimo io faccio
pagare in matematica ok prova fu copiato
da lui tutto l'anno non facevo schifo a
qua devo muovere la cosa vedo a devo
comporre il ruolo che figata incredibile
devo comporre il coso siete scemi
aspetta aspetta che ci sono o le è stato
stranissimo veloce l'ho fatta bene
andiamo al prossimo
torniamo a quello di prima già incasina
la vita avete belle bandiere così centro
le bandiere no dai ti prego questo
rumore mi da sui nervi pro giuro forse
nessun numero deve scontrarsi con un
altro numero può essere spiegatemi il
senso spiega mills e cosa vuol dire sta
roba
ah ho capito sono quante bandiere 5
circondano il numero quindi tipo da
prima la circondano 4 questa circondano
3 questa 5 giusto questo tipo un botto
12345 questa 2
e l'ultimo 1234 michele è un casino e la
tipo prato fiera prato fiorito
praticamente va bene ragazzi siamo
arrivati la cos'è questo faccio una
allora c'è una palla c'è un caso che un
pulsano che è perfetto il pulsante
sposta il coso che cosa prendo la palla
la palla all'apporto qui e sfondo la
porta ci sono certi livelli che sono
delle cagate che morgan è lo capirebbe
chiunque è proprio bella mé anche pietro
ci sono i livelli che sono impossibili
c'è ma mi chiama fatto una via di mezzo
non so ecco in fa come lo dico non dette
[Musica]
la canzone che che suonavamo all'asilo
ok non mi fa per suonare perché non
andiamo andiamo che sono uno slot di
romentino non so cosa che ho fatto la
benetton e che dovevo schiacciare i
tasti un certo ordine ma non ho idea di
quale fosse ma io ho suonato l'unica
cosa che sapevo suonare nella mia vita
ho tolto un bastone partiamo bene la
pietra per creare il fuoco
cioè quando lo scongelare sicuro la leva
sulle marche e la madonna metti la
pietra sotto ok questo è giusto perfetto
adesso prendi la più perfetto scongela
perfetta per ok ho guadagnato anche un
sasso in tutto questo c'è un sasso che
non so cosa vi possa servire ma non ce
l'ho più basso cioè la torcia bertasio
peccato così non fanno rumore sono pato
amiche passo da fuoco alle cose
ciao 1 2 3 4 1 2 1 1 2 3
ciao auguri e figli maschi e stato bello
aveva ri non livelli delle palle a
livelli difficilissimi assurdo c'è un
orologio gigante che segna le sei e
mezza ai lo metterei così giusti phil
hale e io devo unire a 83 perché allora
allora io e quello quindi devo mettere
da 18 sono le 18 e 30 quindi 18 per
forza di ciò dove tre non aspetta il 3
dove va messo con forza 18 e 30 perfetto
ok nakhal come sarà anche agata
allucinante perfetto minchia james bond
cioè la febbre non vale non saprei farlo
neanche da da sobrio a posso tagliare il
filo aspetta chiarissimo
adesso c'è solo quello
che cosa dovrebbe puntare scusami ma
devo evitare che punti la porta allora
fai così no che cagata allucinante vabbè
dai va bene dai continui così fino a
contorno arrivare oggi 75 si spera lui
ha un sasso di si muove mica paranormal
sasso a devo colorare in base ai un
soffitto no ok perfetto una cagata una
cagata vai vai vai vai veloce veloce il
75 cos'è sta roba
salve zio acqua devo fare un qualcosa di
petizione tipo girare raga così ci
sbatto le uova di solito non è proprio
quello e anche la mamma degli hate
trofei sono partiti da cani perché non
riuscivo a fare niente contiamo da dio
non so come va beh meglio così la che
non facciamo domande è sparita la palla
a ma qua è una palla grossa spingi là
dentro col machete spingerà col fuoco al
fuoco ma amo si allaga la palla va su
potevo fare così no va bene non fa non
fate non fate domande ragazzi va bene
così let's go prima di affogare bene non
diventa concitata ammazzo la famiglia
bravissimo o bene questo livello allegro
queste c'è un rampino l'inizio delle
spine carine ho trovato un fuso la sto
prendendo non sto capendo aiuto la
storia non può fare niente questo coso
eccolo maronna ruzgar jobs cherin cento
floors va bene non ho capito che dovevo
solo tirare la porta una cagata dove ho
finalmente un livello che sicuramente
non capiscono anche come mi chiamo ma ci
sto a eva che ne so io
quindi il vaso lo posso spostare ok
adesso in avvio
ok è perfetto pollice verde
non ho capito niente ma va bene andiamo
anni
ma c'è una stella cosa si trova bene in
porta tira su
c'è un coso da schiacciare che devo fare
la devo mettere fasciana la stella qui
sotto
ok c'è la cosa sotto il mattone ma anche
casino ok c'è niente non serviva a
niente ma ho guadagnato un mattone però
non so cosa me ne faccio ma cielo c'è un
[ __ ] polipo e anche nemo pensavo che
il polipo solo mangiasse malissimo
grazie a dio non è successo
o mio dio devo prenderla al volo e
commenti
e vabbè carambola cosa è successo
machete via perfetto raga mammamia
troppo easy una maledetta febbre o 70
regale che schifo vi ho fatto delle
acque ne abbiamo fatti 20 non episodio
solo su così bravo e marco ancora 5 c'è
un alieno rom un orosei buffo ok questo
potrebbe essere più difficile del
previsto perché cambia stanze di
continuo 5 lug 10 10
cosa vi devo far fare un percorso
preciso provo a capire qual'era a destro
dai non può essere uno sinistra o mamma
mia che livello brutto andiamo avanti
come sono diventato stupido primario
intelligente
siamo al 71 inca prova ancora rumore
sottoposti cosi quindi contro devo fare
qua sicuro devo toccare si tre cose
allora 12 alla si muovono avevo visto a
ok ha quindi devo mettere i simboli
giusti allora spetta però a usare prima
tattica fa vj poi vediamo
ah no che mi sembra strano non
funzionasse perché in genere funziona
bene andiamo avanti più la ci sono di
più le macchinine che bello sono tornati
bambini tanto non vedono alla bandiera
di essere più lunga tagliamo la vela
subito però a noi che sono sì ma questo
è un triangolo quindi va sul 3 perché a
tre lati ho studiato a scuola elementare
sciocchini persone a 5 questo ne ha uno
persone salgono a 61 a zero quindi giù
questo ne ha 5
non ho studiato alla scuola elementare
sciocchini ma va a cagare dove metterle
solo in ordine e ciao matematica ma voi
siete scemi per chi vide madama che max
ma perché è al 20 diviso 4 fa 534 fa
20.45 continuano così più due
l'opera 24340 almeno dieci fa 30 30 per
tre fa novanta come tua mamma diviso 245
più 15 fa 60 cav h quindi ciò che anche
15 per 5 75 73 73
e giusto grande madonna
è la numero del piano una cagata 74
stiamo per arrivare al 75 non ci credo
e te pareva che fosse facile cos'è sta
roba dio no vi prego non è vero ma
l'unico dove non compare l'azzurro è
questo qui quello che ho appena acceso
ok poi rosso e questo in basso spinge il
casinò c'è il giallo che questo è il blu
che proprio perfetto 75 è difficile lo
faccio la prossima volta me ne sbatto
ragazzi ci vediamo la prossima volta
sì spero che il video vi sia piaciuto
come al solito ci piace al momento mi
piace anche varisco milione descrizione
sono state mischiate bene ci vediamo
alla prossima visto dai ragazzi
[Musica]